why is there an app for everything
except how to rape a baby thank you guys
so great to be here in Chicago I love
this city
I actually went on a date with a girl
from Chicago once this was like 10 years
ago you know back before I was even a
comedian yet back then I was just a
regular old piece of [__] like you guys
but I'll never forget this date you know
you meet up in a bar we start drinking
we start talking were laughing together
we're connecting it was great but then
we leave the bar we go back to her place
and as soon as we walk in the front door
she passes out cold on her couch now I
went to college
I knew I had a million options
but I'm a gentleman so I did the smart
thing I just got a blanket I tucked her
in I left her a note that said you got
raped people have always told me I'm a
sick sense of humor what do you say to
that
I assume it's relative who are you
comparing me to carrot top then yeah I'm
a little blue to my circle of friends
I'm tame my sisters off the charts
I play practical jokes on her constantly
though I got her so good a few weeks ago
I replaced her pepper spray with silly
string anyway that night she got raped
and she called me the next day going you
son of a [__] you got me so good no no
no no no no as soon as I started
spraying the face I'm like
this is gonna really hurt
hot bucket
now speaking of rape you know what I
wonder I wonder is there more rape at
the equator or the North Pole these are
the kind of things I think about when
I'm sitting home alone and the power
goes out
I wonder is there more rape at the
equator or the North Pole I mean per
capita I know the populations are
different most people think it's the
equator I think it's the North Pole
people think it's the equator because
it's hot down there they don't wear a
lot of clothing guys can see women's
tits they get horny and there's a lot of
[__] going on
that's exactly why there's less rape at
the equator because there's a lot of
[__] going on you can tell there's a
lot of [__] at the equator take a
look at the population figures billions
of people live near the equator
how many Eskimos we got 30 35 no one's
getting laid at the North Pole miss no
[__] call guys say to their wives hey
tonight honey huh tonight huh are you
crazy the windchill factor is 305 these
guys are deprived their horn either
pent-up every now and then they bust out
they got to rape somebody now the
biggest problem an Eskimo rapist has
trying to get wet leather leggings off a
woman who's kicking
[Applause]
you ever tried to get a leather pants
well for someone who doesn't want to
take them off you would lose your
hard-on in the process
up at the North Pole your dick would
shrivel up like a stack of Dimes
[Applause]
Michigan man Curtis Peterson received a
15-year prison sentence for having sex
with his pet pit bull what's that Lassie
woof woof grandpa got stuck in a well
woof woof oh you got raped father sit in
a home just reading the newspaper his
little girl comes running in she's only
six hello darling hello daddy you've
been playing yeah in the park yeah with
your friends until the man came along
till the man came along
yeah man came along and he asked my
friends to leave so it's just me and him
darling come over
whatever happened none of it was your
fault okay darling none of it was your
fault but tell daddy every detail what
happened um he took me behind a tree so
now I could see what you were doing I've
got darling and then what happened um he
took my dress off Oh God what happened
next what um he took his thing out Oh
God darling and then what happened
nothing that was it Oh we'll make
something up Martin I'm uncomfortable in
his world and I'm scared to live I'm not
scared to live but it's scary out here
goddamn I know how flimsy this [__] is I
can see through this I can see the truth
there's an animal inside each and every
one of you it's not good [__] is real
listen I was looking at paper the other
day I'm not making this up there's a
serial rapist in Houston it's nothing
funny about serial rape but what is
noteworthy about this particular rapist
is that all of his victims have been
Lynn enjoy your evening I can't believe
you clapped about that some man raping
men in Houston's
the most gangster [__] so far right like
seven men have already come forward in a
Houston area in report of this
[__] which which means he must
have raped thousands it's a tough phone
call for us to make
it's not like when you get raped ladies
there's no uh society don't give a [__]
about male rape hotline fuss mangobaby
just gotta get up and walk that [__] off
up take that [__] to the grave
[Applause]
kalenna tell my wife some [__] like that
come home I'll dishevel this [__] hey
Willy but it's 3 o'clock in the morning
out [__] another woman just go back
to sleep I need one last joke yeah it's
a little controversial in these days
okay man a list of the world's top 25
amusement parks was released this week
with Disney's Magic Kingdom coming in at
number one not making the list piles
rape dungeon